others who have been trying to qualify  playing their  it will be really fun actually and just  to watch but also Magnus that's the one  Crown that's eluded him throughout his  career he wants to be world champion and  meanwhile he's broken through he has  broken through he has sacrificed that  piece and now arjun's King is in  dangerous territory will it survive  it looks unlikely yeah I mean it's not  just a I mean I don't really see a  threat right now but it's a long-term  attack yes how are you going to stop  there  teamwork of the White Queen her Rooks  the White Knight coming in you can't you  can't stop anything and I mean if you're  feeling sadistic you can even once  you've introduced all your pieces into  attack